- I love your shirt, I wanna steal it.
- Oh, I appreciate that.
- It makes me so happy.
- I thought that,
I just wanted to do
something a little colorful.
- [Kelly] I like it, I'm-
- Sort of getting into fashion
a little bit, you know?
- I'm very into it.
We're coming towards summer.
Spring is here, but we're coming towards,
I'm so excited about summer.
I hear that you collect music, right?
- I do, yeah.
- Like not just records,
is it CDs as well?
- Well, I still have all of my CDs from,
(stammers) dare not say what year, but-
- Oh, mine was '90s, yeah, I
don't know what to tell ya.
(Colin laughing)
- But I still have all my CDs,
but what really mostly, and I
collect tapes as well weirdly.
- I love that.
- Yeah.
- I have cassette tapes.
- I love all boom boxes
that you have in the dressing room.
- I know I literally think
I still have my "Cold Hearted Snake,"
like Paula Abdul black cassette tape.
I have like a few.
- Did you look into his eyes
when you listen to the song?
- I have Willie Nelson one,
Yeah, I'm just saying I
love them, cassette tapes.
They're awesome.
- But yeah,
mostly records that's really sort of the
the main collection, yeah.
- Okay, vinyl, yeah.
- And I've sort of been
doing it now for oh geez,
almost 20 years now.
- Do you do this thing,
'cause whenever I was on tour,
I would love going to each city,
and seeing what their
vinyl places would have.
I love doing that.
- Oh absolutely.
I mean that's how you stay
sane when you're on location,
you know?
- Yeah, just the same.
- What I would do is basically,
wherever I travel, one
of the first things I do
is check out where the records shops are,
and then I go and I take a look around.
It's a good way to get out of
the apartment and all that,
and then what I do you is I label the city
that I bought the record in.
So my collection is all marked-
- [Kelly] Oh, that's cool.
- By where I bought the records.
Just a little "High Fidelity."
- That's real "High Fidelity."
I love that, I love that.
I see there's also some guitars though
in this photo of your records.
- Yeah.
- So you play?
- I do, yeah.
- I didn't know that.
- I do, I play guitar.
I started off as a bass player
when I was in high school,
but I slammed my thumb
into a car door.
- [Kelly] Damn.
- Yeah, it's really pretty gnarly,
and that sort of was the
end of my funk bass career,
maybe a good thing, looking back.
- Maybe (laughing).
(audience laughing)
- Yeah, can't really slap the bass with a-
- Slappin' da bass (laughing).
- Yeah.
So, basically I've been playing guitars,
and I sort of have a collection
of them and I name them,
'cause they're my babies.
The first one I got was
a gift from the crew.
Sorry, no, the cast of "King Kong".
- Oh my gosh.
- And so I named that one
Bloody Nora after Andy Serkis's line.
- Bloody Nora.
- He said, "Bloody Nora,"
and that's the name of the guitar.
- (claps) Oh my God.
- And then I've got, yeah.
Yeah, then I got another
one called Charington,
which is named after the
character I was playing on a show,
and the guy I was playing
my father, Jonathan Pryce
would always call the
character Charington.
So Charington was the name of that one.
- You allow other people to
name your things, I love this.
- I like having the stories behind them.
- 100%, I'm like that as well.
- It's fun, and now I've
got too many of the things.
- Were you ever in a band, did
you ever do the band thing?
- Yeah, I did bands in high
school and in college, yeah.
- [Kelly] Okay, that's fun.
- I liked to gig around
when I was younger,
but there's nothing sadder
than a man playing bass by himself.
Can I get a yeah?
(Kelly laughing)
- Can I-
- Anything?
Yeah, see, he knows, he knows.
- There's Kyle,
our bass player.
(audience applauding)
- [Colin] He knows.
- I think the bass is so sexy.
I love the bass, bass is cool.
Wait do you ever do, I heard that,
are you into podcast or
books on tape, one of those?
- Well, I love a book on tape,
but podcast really sort of
have been the fantastic way
to pass the time.
- In a car especially, yeah.
- Yeah, I mean at the very
beginning of the pandemic,
I sort of stumbled across this thing
that ended up bringing me so much joy.
I was listening to the podcast
and you know you can change
the speeds of the podcast.
Like you can speed it
up just a little bit.
so if the podcast is a little slow-
- What?
- It can speed up.
But I also found that you can
take it down to half speed,
and I don't know if anyone is
familiar with this feature,
but whenever you take
anything down to half speed,
that person sounds drunk.
(audience laughing)
Like really drunk.
- Yeah.
(Kelly laughing)
- And so what I would do
is I would listen to a podcast.
And you know, I was in need of contact,
we were all in need of contact,
and being able to see friends
and whatnot, and we couldn't.
So what I would do was
I sort of thought, like,
"Oh, you know I kind of
miss having go to bars
and then get stuck talking
with drunk people."
So I would film myself listening
to a podcast at half speed,
pretending like I'm being talked to
by an incredibly drunk person.
- You're like, "I wanna
be anywhere, but here."
- Yeah, and it was just a
fun thing that would help me
pass the time.
- Nostalgia,
what are we to do.
- Yeah, yeah.
Just help pass the time.
- That was the look at his new series,
"The Offer" on Paramount+.
So the series is about the
making of "The Godfather".
So, what part did your character play?
- I play a character by
the name of Barry Lapidus,
who is actually not a
real person in real life.
He's sort of a composite
of every single person-
- You look so sharp, okay.
- Oh, thank you.
- Yes.
- A composite of every single person
that did not want to make "The Godfather."
So I'm essentially like a bad guy
who thinks it's a horrible idea
to make what ends up
becoming the most beautiful,
artistic movie of all time.
- Do you like playing those characters,
the ones that are kind
of not liked in the-
- [Colin] I do, I do, yeah.
- It's kind a fun.
- I mean
That one was fun purely because I was,
I got to be the bad guy who said no,
but said it with a smile.
- Oh.
- Which is super fun.
- I know a lot of those men
in the music industry.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Absolutely, yeah.
- They're super fun, Colin.
(all laughing)
(audience applauding)
- So yeah.
- Eh, it's like.
So did you discover any
parts of "The Godfather"
that were real?
Don't say the head of the horse, okay.
- Yeah. I mean I won't do any spoilers,
but they end up making the movie,
that's the biggest spoiler.
- (laughing) What?
- I know, I know.
- What, the Titanic sank?
- I know, I'm sorry, I'm sorry,
I've ruined it for everybody.
- Yeah, spoiler alert.
- No, you know the
thing that I really love
about the series, and I think
it's appealing to both people
who are fans of "The Godfather",
but you don't have to be
in order to watch the show.
It really shows how many miracles
it takes to make a movie.
It's a miracle if the script's any good,
it's a miracle if you
get the cast you want,
it's a miracle if it
doesn't rain on day 38,
'cause you're shooting
nothing but exteriors.
Everyday is a struggle.
Al Ruddy, who the show is
based on, was a producer,
said every day on "The Godfather"
was the worst day of his life,
because it was that challenging to make.
- Training.
- And the one
that surprised me the most
is just actually just how much the Mafia
was involved in the making of the movie.
- To be like, "This is
correct, this is not."
- What?
- Like, this is how
we did it, this is not-
- No, no.
At first it was them
not wanting to make it.
And really-
- just them pushing, oh.
- And then eventually
with the help of the mob,
they kind of got the permission to do it,
and then of course ended
up becoming beloved.
- I think that's permission
you really wanna get though,
right?
- Yeah, oh absolutely.
- I feel like it's a real
raw deal if you don't.
- Yeah, for sure.
- Yeah, that's terrifying.
I'm afraid of acting even more now.
So is it, just more terrified?
Is it true that you get
mistaken for Nick Jonas?
'Cause y'all both are in "Jumanji?"
I Love it.
- Yeah.
On a handful of occasions.
- This is amazing, and
I hope you go with it.
- Well-
- And sign his name.
- This needs to properly be explained,
because someone came up to me and say,
"What's up, fake Nick Jonas?"
(audience laughing)
- Fake Nick Jonas?
- And the reason why they said that
was because in "Jumanji,"
I play like the main kid
that gets sucked into the game,
and in the game, I was
played by Nick Jonas.
- But in real life when you come back
and you live your life.
- It's me.
So in reality, he's fake Colin Hanks,
but no one calls him that.
- That's rude, you know
what I will call him.
- No one calls him that,
and you know, just-
- I'm gonna change his name in
my phone as fake Colin Hanks.
- Please, please.
- That's what I'm gonna do.
- I'll take the photo so
it can be saved to the-
- I'm literally gonna
do it, and I'm gonna,
- Oh, that's fantastic.
- He's gonna love it.
He will think it's funny.
So it's the 50th anniversary
of "The Godfather".
But your 12th anniversary, right?
With your wife?
- Yeah, that's right.
- That's amazing.
- Thank you,
thank you very much, thank you very much.
- [Kelly] So your
daughters are 11 and eight.
- My daughters are 11
and eight years old, yes.
- Oh my gosh, so do you
ever take your daughters,
are they in nature, do they
like camping or anything?
- Oh yeah, I'm trying to get
'em out as much as possible.
- My kids love hiking,
my daughter especially.
- It's the best.
I actually, I had a truck
that had a tent installed
on the roof of the truck.
- Oh yeah.
- So that I could pretty much
drive anywhere and camp out.
And so I got it with the idea
of like taking the family out
to camp a bunch.
But then I realized that
the tent was a little small.
- I was gonna say.
- Yeah, so-
- Those are close quarters.
- I went camping by myself
quite a bit unfortunately.
- You know what though?
That's awesome.
- Hey,
a little soul searching.
- That's called me time.
- Absolutely.
- Every parent needs it.
- Need it.
- Cheers.
(audience applauding)
So you're also, I can tell
already you're into fashion.
- Yeah.
- You like them?
I say, I'm not as, I'm so
like jeans and t-shirt girl.
- I am normally a jeans and t-shirt,
but I've sort of gotten branched out.
I started a handkerchief company.
- (gasps) I like handkerchiefs.
- As a way of getting into
fashion and graphic design,
and I just wanted to scratch
a different part of my brain
and try something new,
and so I started this company
called Hanks Kerchiefs.
- (gasps) You are clever.
- Or Hankskerchiefs, yip.
- Love a play on words.
- I love a handkerchiefs.
- Yeah, so I-
- What a popular time
to have it, 'cause you
can also use it as a mask.
- Yeah, I did.
I did, a lot of people use them as masks.
- [Kelly] I know what a
way to start a business.
- I mean, I kind of so intrigued by 'em,
'cause literally it's
something that everybody
from models to mechanics can use.
Like they're just a fantastic utility.
- I know people always wear,
one of my guitarists, I mean your brother,
he always wears like, you
know it's your brother.
I don't know, I'm just pointing
at Bryce, it's his brother.
But he wears them always on tour,
and he ties them all cool.
I tried one time in my house.
'Cause I was like, "Yeah,
I'm gonna look so cool."
And I was like, "Oh
it's not for everyone."
(all laughing)
No, didn't work, I like wearing
it on the head, but like I-
- I'll give you some pointers and-
- I need all the help in fashion.
- I got you, I got you.
- That's why Candace
makes me look like this, 'cause
I wouldn't look like this.